I'm joined Now by military analyst
retired Air Vice Marshall Sean Bell and
Shauna Stewart was saying you know that
the fact that they're in the war the
anger over these barrages doesn't
doesn't cease does it how significant
was what happened last night well it was
the first time in the last three weeks
that Russia's launched once the one of
these major attacks the Russian defense
minister has claimed this has been a
retribution because of the Ukrainian
alleged attacks at brianska just about a
week ago but these attacks were
conducted all across Ukraine so from
Kiev up to the north and to a dust the
South but there were 10 different
regions here so it was absolutely
widespread uh allegedly um they've
announced six people have been killed
but when you look at the sum of the
devastation it's quite possible that
number will rise the ukrainians say
there were 81 missiles launched that's a
bigger number than we've seen for some
time a whole mix of about eight Shaheed
136 those Iranian drones uh about a load
of cruise missiles but also
interestingly they've also um reckoned
that six of these kinzal Hypersonic
missiles seen here on a fox sound uh
aircraft where all are launched first
time we've seen them and used in that
sort of number now the ukrainians claim
they shot down about 34 of these cruise
missiles and four of the drones but
inevitably some got through and even
those they shut down that well the
debris will fall on the ground it does
appear the Russian were once again
looking at striking energy
infrastructure and here's the uh the key
thermoelectric power plant that was
struck last night you can see the
devastation there and there's widespread
reports of electricity outages across
the country this morning meanwhile at
Zappa regia again a really close hit
there and and this is you know a pretty
significant nuclear plant isn't it it is
um this uh this Aboriginal plant being
held by the Russians since right at the
start of the of the war these Russian
strikes knocked out the electricity part
supply to the zapproach nuclear plant
now why is this important will nuclear
power plants they desperately need
continuous supply of electricity to
provide the coolant to stop these plants
going to meltdown now because it's so
important if the electricity display is
triggered off there is a backup and
that's 20 diesel generators we
understand age of them are online at the
moment the rest are in standby we also
understand there's 15 days supply of
diesel available but the danger is we
start to sound complacent about this
this is the sixth time in the last 12
months that this system the emergency
generators are having to be used as the
last line of defense and this is the
biggest single nuclear reactor in Europe
um the alarming bits unfortunately is
we've quite understandably focused at
the fighting and back mood just over
your right shoulder there but the
fighting continues all the well-off
front from zapreacher developer and
although it's not active the Russians
are concerned that that's where the
punch will come from a Ukrainian counter
attack the Russians are digging in
they're constantly shelling the
ukrainians and all of that's happening
just miles away from a major nuclear
power plant and you mentioned that mud
what is happening up around there at the
minute yeah very briefly The Noose is
tightening around uh back moot yevgeni
prigozin who's the leader of the bargain
group he claims that they're now in
control of back moot in reality it looks
like they control about half it you can
just about to see the back motor River
Running north south through the middle
of back moot it looks likely the
Russians control the Eastern side the
Ukrainian control the western side but
the tricky bit here is this 504 route
it's the only remaining Road in an outer
back Moon that that's what the
ukrainians are using for resupplying
their soldiers and that's becoming
increasingly tense and what I think
that's going to be quite pivotal the
next two or three days but the other on
the more positive notes the Western
armor that's due to arrive for the
spring offensive the Germans and the
poles have announced the 28th of the
leper 2 tanks are due to arrive before
the end of March clearly that's well
below the 300 the president's lensky
asked for but at least it's a start okay
Sean thanks a lot